you said once that you thought that you  would have better luck you might have  better luck if you were gay do you think  that's true yes I if I was gay I'd be  crushing bro I would have so many women  right and that would be a pimp I'm not  gonna even lie if I was gay I would be  the worst lesbian ever what would make  you a bad less because I would have so  many girlfriends yeah how you make you  the best one yeah I never love you that  wouldn't be faithful cuz there's just so  many women I would have all the pretty  women too because I would have game I  got game right right that's incredible  you have that's incredible that you can  predict how your life would be if you  were I know I would yeah that she says  you would have so many women's like you  would be so busy yeah it's such a nice  it's an odd compliment but it's a nice  compliment thank you were gay you would  do very well I'm gonna start taking that  line differently when it's  you